the media and I don't mean every single
person in media of course but by and
large the mainstream media the New York
Times CNN Washington Post and the rest
of it they have been unmasked there has
been a slow unmasking over the last
couple years of it's not even partisan
because partisan isn't strong enough of
a word they have decided that they are
going to pick the winners and losers
they are going to destroy some people
for one thing while saving some people
for another right so a great version of
that right now is what happened with
Brett Kavanaugh you know a year and a
half ago versus the the protection
racket really a mafia style protection
racket that they've run for Joe Biden
just until the last couple days of us
taping this here let that be your
welcome we got with us Dave Rubin it's
time for the don't burn this book club
and I am glad to be covering chapter
eight we just called learn how to spot
fake news which was my second favorite
chapter of this book my favorite was
your travels with Jordan Peterson which
was really the highlight and I can see
why you ended on that one this actually
has my when I was reading this book I
was taking notes in the back and I
actually wrote here a plus because this
has my favorite line in the whole book
and I was like yes he gets it let me
read it to you and let me hear you
expound whether you think this was
rhetorical tongue-in-cheek or whether
it's true but really putting my mild
exaggerations aside the media truly is a
cabal of hyper partisan habitual liars
who are destroying an entire industry
from within now that sounds like a quote
from something I would say it do you is
that tongue-in-cheek how bad do you
think they really are so I would say it
was a little bit of everything meaning
it was a little bit of factual a little
bit of tongue-in-cheek
probably a little under serving as well
but before I fully do that let me just
say one thing malice the reason I knew
you
were the guy to do this chapter with is
that I think you perhaps more than
anyone else in my circle have been like
an acute study or of not just fake news
but Internet culture that led to fake
news because people think of fake news
is like like that's the whole thing in
and of itself that the media is just not
that good anymore but actually it was
the internet culture and the trolling
that you I think are like the master of
explaining that that led to the culture
of fake news so we'll unpack some of
that stuff but as for that line
specifically yeah it was a little
sarcastic it's a little over the top but
the heart of it is exactly true which is
the media and I don't mean every single
person in media of course but by and
large the mainstream media the New York
Times CNN Washington Post and the rest
of it they have been unmasked there has
been a slow unmasking over the last
couple years of it's not even partisan
because partisan isn't strong enough of
a word they have decided that they are
going to pick the winners and losers
they are going to destroy some people
for one thing while saving some people
for another right so a great version of
that right now is what happened with
Brett Kavanaugh you know a year and a
half ago versus the the protection
racket really a mafia style protection
racket that they've run for Joe Biden
just until the last couple days of us
taping this and it's become a cabal in
that they're all in on it together they
all protect themselves when when they
see a pile-on coming for a random person
they all get in on it when when somebody
says something that is perfectly
sensible when I release the book we did
a live stream where I had been Shapiro
and we were talking about opening up the
the economy and he in effect said that
we're gonna have to weigh some costs and
balances and it might be a little more
dangerous acted like an attic roof he
said every everyday has to be like okay
we have to crunch these numbers you
can't just make decisions based on
feelings you have to be economical about
it literally of no choice not only that
but anyone with one flickering but brain
so would know that opening is going to
have some cost so in these politicians
and media people get up there and say
well we can't open until there's no risk
whatsoever because any risk would be too
much risk it's like that's not reality
those are nice words you've put together
and you strung them into a sentence
which is pretty impressive but but this
is not reality and then you watch you
know Media Matters then Clips it and
then Vox and HuffPo and all the usual
suspects that that you talk about all
the time they all get in on it and that
is why although I don't directly quote
you what you refer to as the Cathedral
we're watching the machine breakdown
right now and I think by and large
that's a good thing yeah one of I just
got handed in my ass my ass handed to me
just today and I'm glad to admit it just
like you were talking about Larry older
uh you know Trump had been accused of
saying that he was speaking about white
supremacists as very fine people when in
that literally the rest the sentence he
goes I'm specifically not speaking on
white supremacists I had thought that
believe all women was a right-wing
talking point and I tweeted this I
thought I said they said believe women
which is something we should do people
do tend to tell the truth more than
often they lie and we should give people
the benefit doubt so they feel
comfortable telling their story and I
tweeted this out in Molly Hemingway
within minutes was like no no no no the
hashtag literally was believe all women
and it wasn't you know Twitter randos
this is people at carolyn maloney who's
a very powerful congresswoman from your
and some others and i was shocked to see
how that just seems stupid because women
are human beings they're capable of
lying and now like you said on joe biden
the same people are just pivoting
without a batting and i I've always
argued that they've always been this bad
and now I'm starting to wonder if
they've gotten worse what are your
thoughts on that
I see that's so interesting and that
shows how we all look at things from our
own perspective and then it's why you
need to talk to people because you have
to map your reality against their so
I've usually taken the counter which is
that they used to be better and that
something about the internet and the
ability for the rest of us to now expose
them
has just completely ripped their filter
up on top of the fact that you see all
these they say they're journalists and
then you see their pieces you're what
they're writing but then if you look at
everything else they're tweeting all day
long it's like it's very obvious what
your political biases are you guys don't
even hide it you know you mean you'll
have New York Times in your byline and
you'll tweet some articles that lean a
little lefty or whatever but then
everything else in your feed shows
exactly what you are so I've always
believed that it was it had something to
do with the Internet and exposing the
ideas and that we can see unedited
videotapes
look the the what you just said there
about the very fine people moment Joe
Biden literally launched his campaign
with a video that quotes Trump saying
very fine people and Biden the
implication is that that Trump is
talking about white supremacists which
as you said is exactly the reverse of
what he said but there's a reason he
does it because he knows the media will
cover for him right so who tweets about
it then when it comes out Scott Adams
tried to unpack it i retweeted it you
probably did something a few of us Beco
it's not even about liking Trump so much
it's like it's just about what's reality
here can we but they all do it together
so Biden tweets it out and he knows no
media is gonna call him on it so he can
just keep doing it and I think perhaps
and because we're holding this video for
a little bit as this Biden story is just
breaking maybe by the time we release
this in in about a week and a half I
think it's possible that the Biden one
almost feels like it could collapse the
whole system because all of the me2
people are exposed right now they all
said believe all women and they're all
supporting Biden and it's like now now
what is left what do you people have
left that's the purpose of this chapter
that that fake news is not just fake
headlines
it's about manipulation one of the
things I was curious about you know
someone you had a you know you came from
the Young Turks and had left this
background you talked about this very
often when you are front-page in New
York Times and you and Ian Shapiro are
but but I mean I'm a big serious are
like next to an article that's implying
that you lead to Nazism right and or
just even just a hatred of any kind
maybe not literal Nazism haha Jewish but
like white supremacy and so on and so
forth you
know that everyone you've grown up with
every went to college with probably
reach the New York Times or a large
percentage them do on a personal level
and you know some of them are just gonna
do you know they're not gonna care I
went to high school Dave Rubin they're
gonna see this and they're gonna quit no
way was a Nazi yeah and like what what's
happened to him he's gone full nazi is
that something that affects you I'm like
part of me feels like you don't want to
answer this because you're giving them
what they want but is there a part of
you that's affected by this in a
personal level
well you know when I interview or when
you interviewed me for the book which
will link to below because you asked me
some but I think the most biting pointed
questions about all of this you know I
there's the portion of the book where I
talk about losing a ton of my hair
because when I first got hate I was
getting hate from the people that I
thought were my friends I you know I
mean I just started saying hey liberals
let's be a little bit better let's care
about free speech I mean you can see all
those old videos it wasn't like I was
saying anything hateful and yet they
were saying all these horrible things to
me and people who were invited to my
wedding are now calling me a Nazi and I
literally lost about 40% of my hair and
I was spraying frickin hair on you know
people can watch that why I left the
left video I am bloated and bags under
my eyes and I look freaking terrible and
I felt even worse than that that being
said and and this is partly the purpose
of the book
I am glad that I went through it I made
it to the other side and everyone that
makes it to the other side
James d'amour Brett Weinstein Lindsey
Shepherd and Shapiro the versions of it
that you've gone through everyone that
gets through it you're stronger after
you did it I haven't seen anyone totally
destroyed now that isn't to say people
haven't lost their jobs that isn't to
say there aren't you know people that
aren't public people who have had all
sorts of things but your choice is
either you step up against it and defend
yourself so like when I invited what did
I do when that New York Times piece came
out literally it had my it the you know
YouTube's leading people to the all
right with my giant my head was the
biggest head right there above it in the
New York Times my dad has had a
subscription to The New York Times for
longer than I'm alive something like 45
years he had to go to the bagel place he
goes to in Long Island every Sunday to
have a friend walk up to him and say oh
I didn't know your son Dave is a member
of the alright and then my dad has to
call me and say what are we talking
about here so it's not that they don't
really affect me anymore in that I don't
get stress over it because I think I've
come to know it for what it is you know
it's sort of like well quotes huh you
know it's sort of like a red pill moment
like it's scary at first when you make
that choice but then you get on the
other side and when you see reality for
what it is it's like these people aren't
going to destroy me they're gonna
destroy themselves and that's a little
bit of what I want to impart on people I
want them to know either you will step
up and it will suck for a while and you
know all sorts of bad stuff will happen
but your your choice is much worse
because your choice is the frog in the
boiling pot your choice is to never live
a life that is yours your choice is to
never say what you really think
I just refuse to live that way and I
know you're the same here's the thing
though it's easy for us to say something
like this because you're married you're
about to start a family you have a
successful show I'm you know kind of
happy in my life what do you tell
someone who's like a Nicholas Sandman
what do you tell these cadets who and
there's a headline that says they appear
to be throwing white power symbols it's
really scary when you're a kid and now
you're in the news and people are going
to you just joking be like hey Nick you
know what is the Klan rally
you hear that 20 times
day it's not gonna feel nice so how
would I mean I don't think it's easy for
us to say like oh just live your values
but they don't have that power so well
first off we should say it's it's really
it's not that it's easy for us it's that
we've been through this thing right so
it's easier for me now but it's not like
you know it's not like it magically was
easy but but to your point directly look
Sandman I I've talked to him Nick
Sandman who everyone knows he was the
Covington kid that got slammed and
slurred by the media and the whole thing
and it all turned out to be a
fabrication
I I don't know that he's thrilled that
this thing happened to him but I know
that as a young person he now saw
something and I think has a sense of
purpose around it another example that I
can give you more specifically is Kyle
keshu who used to work with me or he
still does work with us but now he's in
DC but you know he was one of the
parklands survivors who came out as the
gun rights advocate so the media ignored
him at first while they made the rest of
them heroes because the rest of them
were against guns so they're heroes we
find the one kid who believes in gun
rights he's sort of a we're gonna ignore
him for a while and then when we don't
ignore him he's a bad guy well then what
happened to him it turned out they found
some Google Doc where he was you know
saying some bad words with a bunch of
friends they were just doing stupid kids
stuff that you do when you're 15 or 16
years old I know Kyle I love him there's
no way he has a racist bone in his body
but they tried to destroy him and what
happened Harvard literally rescinded
their offer he graduated number one in
his class now I can tell you this I know
that Kyle is stronger now than before
now again these maybe outlier cases and
it sucks I'm not I think you're asking
the right question because I'm not
denying that at your job people will
look at you differently I mean we're
talking about we're not saying for real
Nazis we're literally saying if you just
have some conservative thought if you
just have some libertarian thought if
you just say oh I watch steven crowder
or i watch michael malleus that might be
enough to have these people turn on you
so I'm not saying it's easy but I would
also say this if you're a young person
going through this meaning you're
especially if you're a high schooler but
if you're a college person going through
this it's not that you should
necessarily come out tomorrow
and and just expect no consequence it's
not only should you expect the
consequences but you can figure out ways
to tease it out to your friends so that
you're getting stronger over time and
you're having all you know you don't
have to say to all of your friends at
once I've been read pilled you know and
let's fight about it all day long you
might try it with one friend first test
it out working you know you everyone has
to do it with their own rhythm and
that's sort of consistent with the
message that I put forth in the book
which is I'm not trying to tell
everybody what to do I'm really not I'm
trying to give you some guidelines that
I think can help get you through this
madness eleven rules for living it's I
could I and the thirteenth rule is but
you know what a lot of this look the
truth is that a lot of this is sort of
Jordan Peterson desk in that it's like
if you're gonna make a decision in life
to be who you are it's gonna come with
some cost and you better know how to
stand up for yourself in the process one
of the points I always harp on is that
there is a difference between a bias and
an agenda meaning we're all gonna have
biases probably news are gonna be
slanted we're another just simply a
function of our perceptions if something
you know feeds into how we perceive the
world humans tend to think it's true if
something contradicts well I'm gonna
have to hear some more because that will
have a lot of mental work and one
example I use of bias versus agenda is
Stacey Abrams who lost the Georgia race
for governor you know last year a year
before she's front and center all the
time despite having no resume to speak
of in fact they decided we're gonna make
this person a star in regardless of the
inputs of the data do you think it's
more of a bias over an agenda or am I
being too presumptuous no I think I
think you're ballparking it pretty well
she's a good example of this thing
because she has no resume per se other
than losing the Georgia gubernatorial
race which she claims she won and the
media and many other progressive
politicians claims she won while at the
same time claiming that Trump is the one
that doesn't accept the results of an
election of which they are the ones that
don't still don't accept the results of
the presidential election as well so I
think it's probably a little bit of mix
of both but again this is where it
we're once unmasked it just allows them
to destroy themselves you know there was
an article you probably saw it in
Politico in the last couple days about
governor Whitmer in Michigan who's
become sort of the face of the
authoritarian governor's right now she
doesn't want people planting seeds and
doing landscaping and political ran a
puff piece on her that said it said
something to the effect I'm gonna
slightly butcher the words but this will
be pretty damn close because I'm not
trying to give fake news here it said
something to the effect of you can't
find anyone in Lansing Michigan who
disagrees with her I was like I'm yeah
yeah yeah that doesn't like her and it's
like I'm literally watching hundreds if
not thousands of people on Twitter who
despise her who live in her say but but
putting even if I saw nobody on Twitter
who didn't dislike her the idea you
can't find anybody can't do it there's
literally nobody this woman is Jesus to
it's incredible and by the way a lot of
people didn't like Jesus so that
wouldn't even be at a good example but
it's this type of hyperbolic over the
top over the top stuff that creates this
perception that oh you guys lie about
this you don't tell me the truth when it
doesn't fit your narrative so let's just
burn the whole frickin thing down and I
think this is where you might be a
little more of a burn down kind of guy
than I am I still this is where our
attention is and I love it I still want
to preserve some of this somehow but you
might be right in the long term that
maybe I'm just playing a sort of a
slower degradation game but I'm worried
that if we just tear it all down much
faster than its sort of organically
crumbling that what we get left with is
going to be unthinkable you you are
often attacked personally like you were
the poster child for like for many of
these outlets and they like you know
pick on you Ben gets it much worse than
you I mean there are people whose job at
it just to take whatever Ben says and
construe it as whatever more often than
not
let's name names who do you think what
outlet gets it wrong the most in your
opinion
I mean honestly I don't want to name
names not because I'm afraid but I don't
want to add fuel to the fire because
there are literally people that watch it
there are literally people that watch
everything I do praying that I will say
their name I mean it's it's said and you
know the funny thing is is you know even
as we're talking here and I try to do
this and we all make mistakes but I
always try to talk about ideas not about
people now when I when I mentioned
Governor Whitmer a second ago it's like
I think that doesn't include politicians
in politicians I think you sort of have
to go after them now hopefully you're
going after their ideas and I didn't
attack her personally I I talked about
her ideas but I think politicians it's a
little bit of a different rule but you
know there's a certain set of people
that that are on YouTube or podcast or
Twitter whatever it is that just I'm
good for clicks I'm good for I left left
and survived
they don't want survivors I mean that
really is the truth right I am NOT it's
easy for them to attack Ben or attack
anyone that was a conservative the whole
way through because it's like you were
supposed to be the enemy the whole time
but when someone wakes up and walks and
and not just walks but I've succeeded in
the process of that I've thrived in the
process of that I've come up with a
cohesive set of views and and I say what
I believe and people enjoy that that's
the scariest thing to them so I have no
need to give those guys quarter other
than that that's just a matter of what
the Internet has sort of become and by
the way it's also partly why I started
locals calm and michael malice has one
of the most thriving communities on
locals calm and he owns it and sets the
rules and can do whatever the hell he
wants there I'm gonna put I'm gonna ask
a devil's advocate question okay the
locust circle in hell according to Dante
yes for traitors do you think people on
the Left should regard you as a traitor
and why or why not
woo I like it malice am i a traitor
I'm not a traitor well well I can't
speak exactly to what their what their
beliefs are about me are anymore I
suppose they would view me as a traitor
that they view me as you can find videos
I was a Bernie supporter the irony is
I'm very open about this whole thing you
can literally watch me every week like
addressing the issues and you can watch
the movement it wasn't as if one day I
was like I'm leave a supporter that
makes it worse
you're not even hiding it no but that's
but that's I'm telling you that because
that shows that it's authentic you could
literally watch videos you can find them
of me before the 2016 election going I'm
a Bernie supporter hey liberals let's
fix this thing what's happening to our
side all of those things and then when
that why why I left the left video came
out the Praeger you video that was sort
of me saying goodbye to the left and let
me see what I can do with the right and
by the way there's been great stuff
happening on the right for for quite
some time now and sometimes I think sort
of what you said before maybe I was
wrong about the right the whole time it
doesn't mean the rights perfect but what
you said before about maybe I was wrong
about the media the whole time maybe I
was wrong about about the right for a
certain period of time but that's hard
to accept because it's hard to accept oh
the guys that I kept calling racists and
bigots they're they're not racists and
bigots maybe I was part of the thing
that was racing racist and bigoted that
that's a real problem so could they
could they think of me as a traitor well
I have left their set of ideas and I
have openly spoken about why I did it
and I have found new alliances on the
other side so if that makes me a traitor
then I suppose I'm a traitor one of the
questions I always yell out with
conservatives is you guys say that the
media used to be better and then it got
bad when in your minds with the media
better and usually they don't have an
answer you actually gave me an answer
and this is the first person I've heard
who actually had a good answer and you
put it in 1980 you put it in 1980 when
CNN happened and the news happened 24/7
so now you have to have that much more
content and inevitably that's going to
lead to some journalistic standards
declining if only and also if only
because you're competing with so many
more eyeballs in a television setting do
you think I've always found the
conservatives fons
CNN
to be much more agenda-driven and
dishonest than MSNBC is that your
impression
you know well first off let's give CNN
some credit for a moment because it's
not like when I do that when CNN when
that yeah I do because the point is I
remember I was in I think ninth grade
during the Gulf War around 91 and CNN
was on the ground in a war it was
incredible to watch I remember being in
school and social studies and we would
watch clips and they were doing what
appeared to be real journalism and all
that so I don't want to make it seem
like you know it was all just horrible
all the time and everything else to your
question about well look I think the
reason people attack CNN more than MSNBC
is that MSNBC leans left they tell you
they're leaning left and and so be it
also they have some buffoons on the
network I mean Al Sharpton was given a
show there you know it's like Madoff end
two years running with a Russian
collusion hoax and you know saw no
retribution or there was there was
nothing that happened to her after in
terms of you know do are we gonna change
our thought processes or how we go about
doing these shows CNN was thought of
because it was the first one it was
thought of as more centrist and I think
what's happened is we all eat regardless
of what side you're on I think you do
even maybe subconsciously want centrist
news you want something that feels kind
of decent that maybe doesn't go along
with way you think all the time and I
think that's why CNN gets it all the
time because if they went from being
let's say thought of as centrist they
moved a little bit to the left
but then the Acosta thing happened the
brian Stelter thing happened the
activists sort of let's lie about
everybody and and just dismantle what
journalism is so the bigger thing that
I've been thinking about it well we'll
pick this up in a future show is that
you know a lot of us we spend a lot of
time talking about CNN and in a weird
way it's like if we all just stopped
talking about CNN almost nobody's
watching CNN in a weird way Trump needs
CNN as the as the boob in this thing you
know he needs them as the bad guy and
I'm starting to think that for the for
the rest of us that have broken free may
be our next step in breaking free is
actually really letting go of that stuff
instead of reacting to it I don't know
that we're quite there yet because it
still can brainwash a lot of people but
I think that might be an effective move
those of us that have just moved beyond
this thing okay last question Chris
Hayes earlier this week had a monologue
talking about the terror attack use
Asians against Joe Biden he went into it
at length very dispassionately saying
look what doesn't matter if you like a
person if they're prominent sometimes
these prominent people do horrible
things you have to look at the evidence
and throw your emotions aside as a
consequence of this bio Chris Hayes was
trending on Twitter so given that his
job as a function in the audience and he
has bosses that he has to answer to
can't you say well it's not really the
fault of the press it's the fault of the
population that are demanding they be
told what they want to hear that's a
classic good malice question yes I think
you can right we're all doing it to
ourselves it's what I always say about
free speech I'm not worried right now
about the government coming for my
speech I'm not saying I'm not worried at
all but that's not my primary worry my
primary worry is that we are doing it to
ourselves were actively silencing
ourselves because we are the ones who
unfurl the mob on each other and of
course inevitably it will it will come
for you as for Chris Hayes I would say
this he probably just had his red pill
moment and I would say in a year from
now the Chris Hayes you're gonna see is
gonna be very different and probably far
more like michael malice than like the
Chris Hayes we know in 2020 because
suddenly he is going to see that he said
something true that we all know is true
that you should allegations don't matter
regardless of your political partisan
situation we all know that's the way
it's supposed to work that's all he said
and now who wants to destroy him it's
not the conservatives it's his own
people so if he is able to survive the
mob which is exactly what this book is
about if he's able to do that he's on
the journey so we should pick it up in
one year from today and see where Chris
Hayes is a guy who by the way he's gone
after me many times and I I don't
particularly like and I didn't feel like
offering him any defense because of that
but let's just see where his journey
goes and I and I suspect we know where
this thing ends I just got one more cuz
this just came to me yeah yeah Jake
Weger from The Young Turks they did this
to him he had David Duke on his show
which if you had David Duke on you sho
forget it they would bring it up every
five minutes
and at the end David Duke says I'm not
an anti-semite and janko's not all of
course not and the New York Times
printed that verbatim as if he said he
wasn't being sarcastic and that he took
this at face value
did you just follow that story and how
did that I I did listen I can't believe
you're getting me to do this I will
defend jank in that moment because he
meant it sarcastically from everything
that I could tell he meant it
sarcastically like oh of course you're
not but the New York Times ran with it
as oh of course you're not meaning
you're not anti-semitic so none of this
none of this is perfect that that's the
point but but that right there it's like
the New York Times has failed us at at
almost every level and what I'm enthused
by and what I hope this book will bring
forth more than anything else is there's
a lot of cool voices out there that are
trying to fix the madness and we shall
see if we can do it if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell